قبل ايام انتشر مقطع صادم على مواقع
التواصل في مصر للشاب وفتاه اثناء
ارتكابهما اعمالا منافيه للاداب على جسر
الساحر بالقاهره وفي وضع النهار الشرطه
تمكنت من ضبط مرتكبي الواقعه واحيل الى
النيابه العامه التي قررت بعد ذلك اخلاء
سبيليهما في كفاله ماليه بعد ان اقر
بممارسه الفعل حيث تربطهم علاقه عاطفيه
لكنهما قال ان المقطع يعود الى ابرا
الماضي النيابه طلبت في بيان نشرتها عبر
الانترنت تحريات الشرطه حول الشخص القائم
على تصويره المقطع ونشره وترويجه عبر
مواقع التواصل ومعرفه اسباب تصوير المقطع
انقسم الناس حول المقطع الفاضح فيما راى
البعض ان نشر الفيديو مهم لايقاف في مشاهد
مشابهه في المستقبل قرون مع بيان النيابه
والقوام اللوم على مصور الواقعه سالنا
الناس من يتحمل المسؤوليه
[موسيقى]
اكيد اللي صور مع لو هو المشكله الكبيره
يعني احنا دائما بندور على نسيب الازمه
الحقيقيه وبندور في الحاجات الفرعيه
هو سمعت الولد وكل حاجه باظ
ت موجودين
على السوشيال ميديا انا قبل ما يجي الام
امي غلط انا كتبت قبل ما اطلع للبيت يعني
[موسيقى]
ما ينفعش كانت تتنشر لان النشر ليها ممكن
يكون اذى وسبب مشاكل لناس كثير لحد زي اهل
البنت حد زي اهل الولد مهما كان احنا ما
نعرفش اهلهم ايه
اكثر وندي له اكبر
[موسيقى]
من القاهره
اولا صباح الخير لا طبعا يحاسب مرتكب
الفعل هذا الفعل في القانون المصري يعتبر
من الافعال المنافيه للاداب باعتباره فعل
فاضح في الطريق العام والتي يجرب فيها
المشرع المصري ارتكاب مثل هذه النوعيه من
الجرائم لما فيها من خلال بالحياه والقيم
واخلاق وعادات المجتمعات العربيه انا يعني
لا اتفق شكلا وموضوعا مع محاوله القاء كل
المسؤوليه على الشخص الذي قام بتصوير او
بنشر هذا الفيديو يعني خلينا نؤكد ان كثير
من الجرائم التي ارتكبت داخل المجتمع
المصري على وجه الخصوص خلال الفتره اللي
فاتت لم يكشف عنها الا وجود فيديوهات فتات
المعادي الطفله التي تم التحرش بها في
المعادي لم يكشف هذه الجريمه الا وجود
فيديو تم نشره وتداوله عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي التي كانت يمكن مقارنه
في الكشف عن الجريمه
على ان فكره التصوير في حد ذاتها
يعني فكره تصوير مفيده لكشف عندما نتحدث
عن مغتصب عن متحرش لكن تشهير
بشخص بشاب وفتاه يعبر عن حبهما لبعضهم
البعض لا يكترثان يعني بعيدان لا يؤذيان
اي احد هذا اذا كنت تعتبره جريمه اخلاقيه
او فضيحه فالمصور ساهم بنشر الفضيحه
انا لا اعتبر جريمه اخلاقيه القانون
المصري هو الذي يعتبره جريمه العديد من
جرائم جرائم ال ال يعني جرائم الجنس
والجرائم المتعلقه بالاداب العامه يتم
تصويرها ويتم رصدها من خلال الكاميرات
التي ان تعلمي ان همم يعني غرور المصري
الان بيتم تصوير كل المخالفات التي تتم
عبر الطرق والعديد من المخالفات يعني
متداول ومعروف في الشارع ان تم التصوير
بعض المشاهد لمخلفات في المرور لافعال
منافيه داخل السيارات هذا هذا التصوير في
حد ذاته ودفع الغ الماليه عن هذه
المخالفات كان سبب في التوقف عن ارتكاب
مثل هذه الافعال مره اخرى من امن العقاب
اساء الادب وللاسف اصبح الامر انه الناس
بقت بتخاف اكثر منها تعمل حساب للقيم
والاعداد والتعليم ان الناحيه القانونيه
انتهاك الخصوصيه هو الجريمه ايضا تم
التصوير وتم النشر طب قبض على على يعني
همم الفاعلين
لما حضرتك خصوصيه
خليني بس اوضح مع حضرتك الانتهاك الخصوصيه
مرتبط بالتصوير بالاماكن الخاصه ان انا
اصور حضرتك في بيتك او في جلسه خاصه في
اجتماعات الخاصه انما كونوا موجود على
الكوبري في الشارع في مكان عام هو في حد
ذاته جريمه النيابه العامه لم تخلف بينهم
لعدم ارتكابهم الفعل والنيابه العامه لم
تتوقف عن الاستمرار في السر في الدعوه انا
اتابع القضيه عن استمرار الدعوه واخلاء
سبيلهم ان هم همم في حاله براءه انما هم
متهمين ولا قضيه ما زالت مستمر
نتحدث عن عمر 18 19 اطفال ربما غير واعيين
غير مدركين ليه القوانين والتابعات
المجتمعيه والقانونيه لما حصل لهم انه
يعيشوا قصه حب بسبب ضغط الاهل الضغط
حضرتك احنا القانون المصري بيعتبر سن
الطفل قانون 12 لسنه 96 بينتهي سن الطفل
في 18 سنه فما فوق 18 ده في وفقا لاحكام
القانون مش طفل احنا لو سيبنا المساله ان
اي حد يطلع في اي مكان عام في الشارع بقى
فوق الكوبري ونقول ان هم بيحبوا بعض
يعني ويكون نفس هذا المشهد يبقى احنا
فتحنا فوضى في الشارع المصري الارتكاب
الفواحش والاعتداء على القيم وعلى الدين
همم المساله في حد ذاتها ما هوش تصوير
الخصوصيه ولا الكشف الخصيه الناس ولا
انتهاك لهذه الخصوصيه وانما هو عرض للناس
نوعيه من الجرائم حتى يكون عبره
طب النيابه المصريه اليوم نشرت بيان طلبت
فيه بالتحري عن المصور ما هي عقوبه حكم
عقوبته من الناحيه القانونيه
اولا مساله الكشف او البحث عن الشخص اللي
قام بنشر الفيديو تصوير الفيديو ده مش من
باب ان ان الفعل في حد ذاته وجريمه وانما
تعمد النشر بعد فتره طويله جدا من ارتكاب
الفعل يشكل صوره من صور التشهير او
الاساءه انما التصوير في حد ذاته لا يشكل
جريمه لانه مش مش انتهاك الخصوصيه مش في
مكان خاص تصوير في حد ذاته كشف عن جريمه
اتصور ان هيبقى ده حل رابع جدا لكثير من
اللي بيرتكبه في الحدائق العامه وفي
المتنزهات وفي بعض المواصلات العامه انه
يرتكب بس هذه الافعال لانه لما يعرف ان في
كاميرات بتصوره هيفكر الف مره انه يعمل ده
لو توريكه ولو تركها للاشخاص حريه ان
يختاروا من يحبون لما راينا مثل هكذا
فيديوهات ولا ما تولد
فيه احيانا
تدخل في اختيار المحبين يا استاذ نادين
تحب اللي انت عايزه ايوه بس هم ضحايا
يعني لمشاكل المجتمعيه للظروف الاقتصاديه
ما فيش امكانيه للجواز العوز الفقر بشكل
اجتماعيه كثير لكن ده لا يسمح ان احنا
نخرج في الشوارع ونرتكب الفواحش وكل واحد
يجيب واحده واخ يمارس معها فعل فاضح في
الشارع ونقول ان ده بسبب الضغط يبقى كده
بندي مبرر لارتكاب جرائم ايضا ونقول ان
الضغوط الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه هي المبرر
لارتكاب الجرائم في الشمال بس ما هي عقوبه
التشهير في مصر
العقوبه هتكون الغرامه اللي ممكن تصل الى
10,000 جنيه
للجريمه من جرائم القرنين
لو احنا بنطبق القانون تطبيق صحيح واتصور
ان النيابه العامه احرس مني على ذلك الولد
والبنت هم اللي هيتحبسوا لان دي جنحه
معاقب عليها بالحبس مش معنى ان تم اخلاق
سبيلهم قفل ملف اصليه لان انا كان بيخلاء
سبيلهم نظرا لظروف السن لكن يعني هيتحكم
بمزاله القضيه مستمر
هل يجب كمان ان يحبس همم المصور لانه مثلا
يعني المسؤول عن موقع اباحي هو مسؤول
ومتهم يعني في نفس الجريمه الفيديوهات وان
لم يكن في الصوره وهو خلف الكواليس فهو
شارك المصور
يعني الكلام اللي حضرتك بتقوليه سليم جدا
لو استخدمنا نفس التعبير بان حضرتك قلت
انه موقع اباحي هو ده متناشرش في موقع
اباحي طيب
مواقع غير اباحيه انما الاستخدام كان
الاستخدام سيء ربما استخدام سيء لكنه رصد
وقع حقيقيه للكشف عن جري
احمد ولكن نشر على كل المواقع الاجتماعيه
طيب نشوف راي الاخر مع من نيويورك مع
المحامي احمد موسى سيد احمد اهلا بك ما
رايك بهذه الواقعه وبالتصوير يعني يحاسب
المصور المرتكبير فعلا اتفضل
اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك
مبسوط طبعا انا موجود مع حضرتك مش هاطول
على سيادتكم الموضوع من الاول للاخر طبعا
كل الاطراف اخطا فيه الولد والبنت اخطاؤهم
ما فيش اي احد يقدر ان هو يقول ان هم همم
ما فيش عندهم خطا لا عندهم خطا وخطا كبير
جدا المصور كمان عنده خطا وخطا كبير جدا
عفوا لان المصور هنا
الساعه في انتشار الفيديو وساعد في انتشار
الواقعه يعني
كان يقدر بكل سهوله ان هو بعد ما صور يقدم
السوق الفيديو للجهات المعنيه او الشرطه
لاتخاذ اللازم لكن هو اللي هو عمله ساعه
في نشر محتوى يكاد يكون اباحي نشره على
اثار التواصل الاجتماعي
ساعد واساهم وبقهوه في نشر المحتوى اذى
الولد والبنت منعهم حتى من لانهم يقدروا
يدافعوا عن نفسهم ده الرغم من اخطائهم ده
بالرغم من الخطا كبير جدا ولكن قدام
القانون كل متهم من حقه ان هو يدافع عن
نفسه هو للاسف الشديد بالفيديو اللي هو
نشره خلى ان هم فقدوا جزء كبير جدا من
التعاطف معهم الناس كلها دلوقتي بتطالب
بالقصاص منهم
وابنهم يتم سجنهم وحبسهم بالرغم طبعا ان
بعد حتى اني اخذتها الناس ما عندهاش رضا
بالقرار للاسف الشديد الناس كلها
بتهاجم الولد والبنت طبعا مش بندافع انا
ما احنا بندافع عن الموقف القانوني ان ما
ينفعش اي حد يستبيح الناس ويصورهم وينشروا
الفيديوهات على الانترنت بيساعد في تدمير
اسر كامله بيساعد في تدمير المتهمين نفسهم
يعني حتى انت كده مش بتدي فرصه للمتهم ان
هو لو تراجع خطابه ان هو الناس تتقبله مره
اخرى فطبعا لا المصور اخطا واعتقد ان هو
اخطا خطا جسيم اساء استعمال وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ساعه في نشر محتوى اكاد يكون
محتوى اباحي ونشره على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي الفيديو حقق انتشار كبير جدا
ناس كلها سمعته الناس كلها شافته بالتالي
سبب ضرر للموقف القانون المتهمين
طبعا من وجهه نظري ان هو اخطا خطا كبير
واستحق الحساب طبعا ولكن الى الان لم يتم
توجيه اتهام رسمي له يعني يقبل عامه امرت
بالتحري عن مصور الواقع لكن لحد دلوقتي ما
فيش توجيه التهامي لمصور الواقع احنا ما
نعرفش النيابه هتوجه الاتهام ايه ما نعرفش
ان حتى لو تم الوصول لمصور الواقع النيابه
هتحقق معاه وهتحفظ الامر مش يعني مش مش
موضوع مش هيتطور اكثر من كده او هتحيله
للمحاكمه لسه ما حدش يعرف فبالتالي احنا
بنتكلم في الاحتمالات من وجهه نظرنا كم
محامين او كماليين في اختلاف طبعا انا من
وجهه نظر ان هو اخطا اجازتين يستحق العقاب
لانه همم انتهت طبعا مش هاقول انتاج حرمه
الحياه الخاصه لان الفيديو اتصور في مكان
عام وطبعا خلاص هو
صوروش في بيت ما صوروش في عربيه خاصه لكن
احنا هنا بنتكلم ان هو اتصور بعض الاشخاص
في طريق عام ونشر المحتوى الذي
كانوا بيصلح امانه
يعني ما بعرف ملاحظه ان هو كانه قاعد
مترصده لهم لهذا الشخصين لانه مش الفيديو
انتشر بخلال الفعل لا هو صورهم من قبل
وقاعدين قبل ما يصير هذا الموضوع كانه
قعدوا قاصد يعني عن قصد عمد دي حقيقه
وكمان هو عامل زوم بنسبه كبيره جدا على
الولد والبنت فهو مترسب لهم لو احنا لو
احنا كنا نكافئه امتى لو هو ترسل لهم عشان
يقول الصدقاءهم او يرصد اخطائهم وقدم
الفيديو للجهات المعانيه ساعتها احنا كنا
نسقف له ونقول له بربه عليك كده انت هنا
ساعات ان انت تمنع ان الجريمه دي تحصل مره
ثانيه لان هيتقبض عليهم
لكن انت اخذت الفيديو نشرته علشان تحقق
مشاهدات وتحقق انتشار فما تجيش دلوقتي
تقول لي انا كنت بحارب الجريمه او بحارب
واقع معينه ان انا اخذت الفيديو نشرته لا
حضرتك لما نشرت الفيديو اذيه اختي اذيه
زوجتي اذيته يعني فكرتك انت يا استاذ احمد
انه لو صور الفيديو كان لازم ياخذه للجهات
المعنيه او للشرطه وما يشهد والمواقع
التواصل شكرا جزيلا طيب
شكرا جزيلا لكم على تواجدكم معنا صباح
العربيه شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]